[Musik]
die seychellen ein naturparadies im
indischen ozean
es ist der arbeitsort schon ornella
weideli und ihrem team die biologin
erforscht hier zwei ab
[Musik]
geh zur ein dann bewegen wir uns entlang
der sandbank im saint joseph atoll
wimmelt es von jung haien
denn hier sind sie sicher vor ihren
feinden das team fängt sie mit einem
netz ein
die frau erzählt trainer didi bei der
rückenflosse sie wirklich große also ist
er grün ist im zdf gesagt
die hersteller
wir sind im indischen ozean auf den
seychellen
[Musik]
ornella weiter geforscht auf der insel
darß und im nahegelegenen saint joseph
atoll
hier am äquator ist die
sonneneinstrahlung sehr stark zum schutz
tragen alle kopfbedeckung und tücher
ornella arbeitet für die stiftung save
our seeds ryan bailey ist deren lokaler
wissenschaftlicher direktor wurde der
schon mal gefangen
er ist neu ein zitronen hai ein kleines
männchen männchen der junge zitronen
high wird mit einem chip versehen
so erkennt ihn das team später wieder
dann kontrollieren wie die chipnummern 2
176 zwischen 50 meter kilometer und sehr
wichtig für die haie bleiben wenn wir
das auch torschütze
das ist die ganz jungen tierschutz das
ist natürlich perfekt
ausgewachsene zitronen haie können über
drei meter lang und bis zu 30 jahre alt
werden
49 punkt 355 punkt 163 punkt 1 jetzt
nehmen wir noch eine dna-probe dem
jungtier wird ein winziger teil der
rückenflosse abgeschnitten
anhand der dna kann später der
verwandtschaftsgrad zwischen den tieren
rekonstruiert werden
die frage ist natürlich sehr
hey und es ist unglaublich dass man wo
man nicht mit menschen kontakt ist
[Musik]
seit drei jahren ist das indonesische
tauchparadies drei lampard für den
schweizer jonas neue heimat und
herzensangelegenheit zugleich das ist
möglich aber so sieht also das heißt wir
sind wirklich sehr hoch mit dem anderswo
hier natürlich sehr freut sport spricht
und sport verzichtbar 2 nach hinten und
das problem ist
[Musik]
sein lernzentrum betreibt jonas müller
in indonesien in südostasien bei west
papua liegt das tauchparadies reiter am
cut der 28 jährige glarner will dass die
kinder hier die ökologischen
zusammenhänge kennen lernen
das geht nur mit konzentration hört sie
ihr müsst euch jetzt konzentrieren wenn
jemand eine geschichte erzählt nicht
einfach dasitzen den wind genießen und
relaxen verstanden
dann bildet jetzt gruppen bitte jonas
führt ein einfaches leben zusammen mit
den einheimischen dafür gab er seine
karriere auf kam hierher und lernte
indonesisch
ich möchte nicht auf sicher und
wunderschöne natur zuhause natur die
sätze der natur mit dem zucker bewohnt
sie sind da so stark von der natur
abhängig wie noch wenige mannschaft
wovon handelt diese geschichte vom
abfall
wenn jemand etwas sagen er streckt bitte
auf und ich wähle jemanden aus abraham
was meinst du
ihr sollt nicht leiden
warum will das essen
er hat das im buch gesehen
er hat angst dass die schildkröte was
macht es ist was will sie essen
[Musik]
tourismus natürlich problemlos problem
verstanden ist wie der lokale doch gar
nicht für sie am strand liegt oder dass
plastik genau das außerdem die chance
verstanden ist und was die hand gegangen
und haben sie zu unterstützen
wer ist denn der gruppe 2
ein glaubwürdiger du bist in gruppe 3
[Musik]
auf den seychellen erforscht die
bernerin ornella weideli mit zitronen
und schwarz
an einigen orten der welt sind diese
gefährdet doch hier bietet ihnen das
atoll schutz und sie kommen zahlreich
vor anker
nachdem bella und ihr team die tiere
vermessen und gechipt haben
entlassen sie sie wieder in die freiheit
weder ein schwarz spitzen riecht und ein
zitronen heiligste wie sehr flexibel
du musst mir selbst was mit dem körper
772 den hatten wir schon mal
es ist so spitze wir hier so ist eine
gute informationen wie ist eine theorie
die rückenflosse des schwarz spitzen
riffs ist wie ein individueller
fingerabdruck an ihr und den daten im
chip können die forscher das tier wieder
erkennen du kannst hier eine zwei
schreiben 51 punkt 6 und 61 punkt 6
wir lassen ihn frei
es ist schon 10 46 das ist sie zum gare
und so mag im moment nach auschwitz ist
noch mal besucht ungar bisher bei der
untreue geht es jetzt noch genau wo mark
waters ist es wolfgang sehr schnell
umgegangen ist
[Musik]
viel hänge perfekt
zwölf flugstunden entfernt ist das neue
jahr gerade mal einen tag alt wer kann
bleibt zu hause
denn in zürich bläst ein eisiger wind
doch einige mutige beeindruckt das nicht
der tauchclub zürichsee trifft sich zum
alljährlichen neujahrs anlass tauchclub
präsident avi uhr und seine tochter
tanja sind seit stunden wach und haben
bei jung und glühwein für alle
zubereitet sie stehe ich die tage im
jahr
wir machen natürlich neujahr am ersten
januar geht es nicht gut mit allen
morgen dürften außerdem auf der zweite
anlauf machen wir jetzt der regelmäßig
sieht 220 jahre jetzt im jahresbericht
das wasser der limmat beim zürcher
bausteins leben ist gerade mal vier grad
so stationiert und umstiegsmöglichkeiten
begleiters aber selbst die
leidenschaftlichen hobby taucher haben
schon so einiges aus der limmat gefischt
vom gebiss bis zum tresor
hast du schon gefunden die goldkette 20
minuten was auch in boston und möglich
ist und was mit musik neubaus wackere
velo haben wir schon gesehen und gehört
und gesehen dafür war wieder so ein ding
gemacht dass die herzliche grüße der
flugzeuge pro jahr machen richtig stolz
sein rampe hundert meter vom see tore
das hat eine abgabe von fünf toren
unterschied ob ich weiß wie gut das
passt es ist gar nicht um das metall
jetzt die chance wieder einige hundert
sondern jeden in tegelen gar gestand u12
garten stand das velo sie das umsetzen
doppel platzieren
das ist eben wir interessant
offiziell wünschen sich die taucher
allerdings etwas existenzielles luft
agi und tochter tanja vergessen die
kälte und sind gespannt was sie unter
wasser erwartet
[Musik]
hinter indonesischen bauchregion reiter
am bass sind die kinder voller eifer bei
der sache
sie reinigen den strand vom abfall die
strömung angeschwemmt hat
[Musik]
machen wir hier noch sauber und bringen
alles okay
oder sie gern das phantom
[Musik]
was ist das problem mit diesem abfall
die kirchen bleiben im hals stecken mal
wenn sie im wasser sind wie das aus wie
lang lang und der manta ist es was
passiert er stirbt hier wirft jemand ein
papiertaschentuch ins meer wie lange
dauert es bis es abgebaut ist einen
monat nur einen monat ein plastiksack
wie lange dauert der 20 jahre 20 jahre
was frisst die schildkröte im buch und
was hat sie gemeint frisst sie eine
qualle eine kleine schildkröten fressen
plastik war der schiene mantas alle
unsere freunde im meer können daran
sterben
[Musik]
es ist ein anfang aber das riesige
abfallproblem können die kinder nicht
lösen
[Musik]
wer zum beispiel die plastik aus der
sache dass die kleiderkammer ist riesig
was wir drauf haben
dafür plant man irgendwo mit dem
flugzeug nach singapur
das macht da nichts sehen und wird
daraufhin von plastikabfall nur eine
professionelle abfallentsorgung kann die
umwelt nachhaltig schützen
jonas hat eine vision stellt für abfall
in weishaupt von der bereitschaft und
dann müsse man das boot oder gar nicht
jeder als größte so zum beispiel zweimal
pro monat jeden dort das heißt
eigentlich dass heute immer den druck
bringen auch nachweise und muss
entsprechend nach mbh und damit wichtige
bedingungen auch verbrannt
oktober muss die regeln der nächsten
zwei jahre das war einfach genial und
von extrem wichtig
[Musik]
auch am grund der limmat hinterlässt die
moderne zivilisation ihre spuren
kg und tanja folgen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
auf den seychellen ist ornella weideli
auf der forschungs insel der oz schon
früh auf den beinen
[Musik]
note 2 wovor sparen grunde umgeschmissen
ornella will nun die daten von der
gestrigen exkursion auswerten
[Musik]
das verhalten von haien interessiert sie
so sehr dass sie es zum thema ihrer
doktorarbeit gemacht hat
also gestern herrin über 100 sekunde
daisy bundes 27 29 schwanger wurde und
zwar im fünfter oktober 2007 also nicht
sehr lang hat das haupthaar zu ca
und natürlich an tina und zum teil neu
geboren richtig dick ist jetzt wie die
sie voll so voll und das ist eigentlich
da wo sie hey was sehr groß zwischen
vollgestopft ist mit dem factory sein
vermutet deshalb sehr teuer denn die
tiefer lagen sie könnten aber ist das
geld gut aber es ist typisch dass sich
also der umfang geld zurück und geben
die alle drei orchester von heike de
[Musik]
an der limmat kann der tauchclub
zürichsee allerlei trossingen an land
ziehen
gegenstände die mit oder ohne absicht
auf dem grund der limmat landeten
[Musik]
warum verdienen
doch die szene haben auch richtig nur
gewonnen die reparatur wird der
hochschule zu machen
in solchen fällen informieren die
taucher die polizei gegenstände die
niemandem gehören werden entsorgt
letztlich seien die solarzellen und das
ohne brille
der letzte kontakt zu haben du bist aber
für die stadtkasse so machen zu machen
neueste studien
[Musik]
schluss
in der bekannten tauch region von reiser
am platz ist die marine artenvielfalt
überwältigend 1400 fischarten gibt es
hier
[Musik]
und über 500 korallenarten
jonas müller will dass diese prächtige
natur erhalten bleibt
doch die insel aber rag ist innert
weniger jahre zu einem touristenmagneten
geworden das hinterlässt spuren in der
indonesierin maja hat jonas eine
verbündete für sein engagement für die
umwelt gefunden
erinnerst du dich dieser anlage steht
war unter tauchern der berühmteste
jahren überall gab es für schwärmen
die sind verschwunden und da die schönen
kurven schauen wir diese will diese
großen boote das ist wahnsinn
es wird all die schönen korallen
zerstören
jonas macht seinem ärger luft
geiz und touristen ermahnt er zu mehr
sorgsamkeit das parkverbot für die
schiffe bleibt unbeachtet
dass sich massa tourismus drachen vom
massentourismus und das ist die frage
die für psp system kapitalismus der die
meisten umsätze der choral anrufe die
meinen das ist aber corolla haben
es wird überprüft
die eintrittsgebühren sollte es mussten
stehen bestehen kann ist das ziel
gemacht
das ist limitiert sieht es zum beispiel
zwei bot maximaldauer stehen zu unserer
verwaltung interessantes buch
[Musik]
jonas und seine kollegin maria wollen
ein zeichen setzen und eine
nichtregierungsorganisation mit
einheimischen gründen
sie soll helfen die natur zu schützen
[Musik]
das gute daran ist wir könnten wegen
genau solche probleme wie der
anlegestelle zu der lokalen
aufsichtsbehörden und hätten so eine
gesetzliche basis
na ja dann sind es nicht nur wie als
privatperson
[Musik]
nur wenn jonas auch einheimische
überzeugen kann in der organisation
mitzuarbeiten können sie gemeinsam die
folgen des massentourismus bekämpfen
[Musik]
da wo es besonders kalt ist am
polarkreis zwischen island und grönland
wird es ihm warm ums herz
ich freue mich riesig es ist glaube
nämlich traut er gespannt und damit
natürlich
gruppe tanzen reist aus zürich an seine
leidenschaft gilt dem filmen
fotografieren und eistauchen dafür nimmt
der multimedia journalist zusammen mit
seiner frau renee so einiges auf sich
das ist gestört was es dazu braucht also
ich habe gesagt sagt kilo los bloß noch
mal die 23 sehen wir uns gesagt so
nachts kann ich noch ob die homepage
zeigt das ging ja alles vom träger haar
aber der herr ist so wahnsinnig tief
das heißt das gepäckstück mehr
der passagier
[Musik]
robert hansen ist in grönland in der
größten stadt an der ostküste
tassilo gerade mal 2000 menschen leben
hier
mit deiner man kann immer sehr wohl
gefühlt und grönland ist so einen traum
sie aus dem hinterhalt ich habe vom
vater jürgen k
und ich immer wieder angelegt so dass
aktuell arbeite mich immer sehr
fasziniert und das hat fast 50 jahre
braucht bis ich das denn tatsächlich
einige löffel umsetzen
[Musik]
das bedeutet der ort mit einem see
die menschen hier leben von der
fischerei und vom tourismus besonders
angetan hat es robert der komposter
hafen
[Musik]
manchmal erzählen jeder schönste ort
aber kein verrat sondern auch schönste
das ich kenne das wird es spricht
natürlich jetzt sicherlich am bioland
klar es geht bei ca das thema ist zeigen
sie was motiviert das gut denn ist kann
gar nicht so viel lüge oder
infrastrukturen in wahnsinnig groß ist
hat dann muss man daheim blieben gar
nicht mehr wo alle welt will aus am
schluss auf den fußabdruck wendel ort
und mehreren in westeuropa immer öfter
werden stars mehr kaputt macht das
fördert das völlig klar
[Musik]
die seychellen sind seit langem ein
beliebtes ferienziel ein teil der region
steht bereits unter schutz
ornella weitere konzert vier jahren
regelmäßig hierher
jetzt taucht sie mit ihren kollegen ab
um die wasserwelt zu inspizieren
platz
lebensraum sind
er bekam für sie
da ich mit
daley ist der lokale wissenschaftliche
leiter der schweizer stiftung save our
seas er und michael scholl der direktor
der stiftung wollen erreichen dass auch
die region um der es unter schutz
gestellt wird
[Musik]
schon bald zeigen sich verschiedene
reihe
[Musik]
geschützte orte wie diese höhle werden
vom glas fischen belohnt
der große fledermaus fisch kennt keine
scheu
[Musik]
die unterwasser gäste werden beäugt
auch von einem zackenbarsch
grüne meeresschildkröten sind hier seit
über 20 jahren geschützt und sind
seither verbreitet
[Musik]
ryan wird von einem riesen drücker fisch
attackiert der sein revier verteidigt
er kann schmerzhaft zubeißen
[Musik]
es ist schlimm was passiert das mit der
korallenbleiche 2016 die ursache für
koran gleiche liegt bei der globalen
airline das erste mal beobachten wir
dass 1998
es war eine folge von klimawandel und
globale erwärmung
es wird noch häufig auftreten außer wir
ändern unseren lebensstil auch die
attacke des drücker fisch ist ein thema
es war lustig du wurdest von den
angegriffenen hinter dir waren zwei haie
die niemand beachtete der riesen drücke
fisch hat mich in die flosse gebissen
er hat sein nest verteidigt tötet keine
eindringlinge das hat so lustig
ausgesehen
es war nett wie du meinen er kam in der
hoffnung dass er mich wählt nimmt auch
den da ist mehr dran
[Musik]
zurück in casilas
ja der hoffentlich nicht sehr bewegt im
moment noch relativ viele eigenschaften
meinen dass die schweiz wieder im sommer
den choral an die jetzt schon wieder
alles zur krone muss gott jetzt noch ein
paar managers als erster versorgung
seiner marke wieder kommt das heißt
frische lebensmittel herstellen
[Musik]
krone teufels kilo das ist für einen
franken für einen stolzen preis
spaghetti napoli allerdings scheint
irgendwie ein komisches ja das ist
natürlich in der nächsten folge muss
sich robert hansen das eistauchen hart
pickelhart verdienen in indonesien
bekommt jonas müller besuch von seinen
eltern aus glarus
und ornella waidele taucht ein in die
zauberhafte welt der manta rochen
[Musik]